[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para recorrer y analizar el
desarrollo de la copa américa y la
eurocopa estos son nuestros titulares
argentina venció 1 a 0 a paraguay
aseguró su clasificación a los cuartos
de final de la copa américa el equipo de
lionel scaloni volvió a mostrar sus dos
caras pero se sostiene la fuerza de
resultados ponemos la lupa en el
rendimiento de la albiceleste
chile también se metió entre los ocho
mejores de la copa américa con el empate
1 a 1 ante uruguay
la celeste rescató un punto pero volvió
a dejar dudas en su rendimiento
analizamos el momento del equipo del
maestro tabárez
bélgica y países bajos cerraron con
puntaje ideal la fase de grupo son los
diablos rojos vencieron 2 a 0 a
finlandia y una naranja superó 3 a 0 a
macedonia del norte se anotan en la
carrera por el título
como cada día le damos la bienvenida a
nuestra analista sarah castro directora
del diario 'as' de colombia sara
bienvenida hola federico como siempre un
gusto hablar de fútbol con ustedes bueno
comenzamos este repaso con la copa
américa se completó la tercera fecha de
este torneo con la acción del grupo a
que deja clasificados a argentina y a
chile en el primer turno chile y uruguay
igualaron 1-1 eduardo vargas adelantó a
la roja y arturo vidal en contra
equilibrio para la celeste luego
argentina venció por la mínima paraguay
con el gol de alejandro gómez ahora nos
quedamos con este último partido y
ponemos el foco en argentina que cambia
nombres pero se repite en su diagnóstico
un comienzo a todo vapor y después
empieza a decaer sobre todo en los
segundos tiempos como se analiza esta
dualidad de argentina así que se dedicó
parece que este es un equipo en
constante construcción no sólo por los
seis cambios que intentó implementar
escalón y en el partido de ayer
además planteando algo interesante que
era ver a di maria a papu gómez y alan
el mes y en esa zona de gestación creo
que gana más de lo que juega y esa es la
preocupación luego creo que lo importa
lo que se puede resaltar es que es un
equipo que está sabiendo sufrir en esos
momentos en los que el juego no fluye ha
sabido resistir y creo que eso es
importante de cara a la idea y sobre
todo a sostener la figura del entrenador
por el otro lado tuvimos una paraguay
que va a quedar con algunas buenas
sensaciones sobre todo después de ese
segundo tiempo pero ahora se le viene
justamente la parte más difícil de esta
fase de grupos que se puede esperar del
equipo de berisso hizo un partido
interesante el equipo de berisso creo
que estuvo bien planteado lo de almirón
fue muy importante intentando
desequilibrar por la banda ya habían
tenido problemas en la definición en el
partido contra bolivia lo que es un
equipo que puede pelear lo que pasa es
que los rivales que se vienen son
potentes vamos a ver si un chile que ya
está clasificado puede hacer algunos
cambios además por digamos el desgaste
físico que también tiene el equipo de
martín lasarte pero ha sido interesante
ver este paraguay que ha estado
compitiendo sin duda en un grupo que es
bastante parejo
nos quedamos en este grupo y vamos a
poner ahora el énfasis en uruguay y en
chile es el primer punto que consigue la
celeste en el torneo levanto algo su
rendimiento sobre todo a partir de ese
gol del empate ante la roja pero los
cuestionamientos sobre el maestro
tabárez son cada vez más duros que es lo
que le está pasando a este equipo de
uruguay que siempre nos acostumbra a ser
protagonista que tiene nombres
importantes pero que todavía no
encuentra su rendimiento y suma cinco
partidos ya sin ganar
siento que este uruguay le está faltando
en la evolución del juego el adn
uruguayo tiene unas características muy
importantes y los jugadores que han sido
estandarte sin embargo en la gestación y
sobre todo en la elaboración colectiva a
la hora de atacar ha sido muy deficiente
creo que sí tuvo una presentación mejor
a la que tuvo frente argentina y eso se
vio por momentos e incluso los primeros
minutos del partido intentó presionar
alto robar pelotas y generar acciones de
gol como la que tuvo cavani en los
primeros minutos del partido los
cuestionamientos seguirán también es un
ciclo que ya está llegando a su fin con
el maestro tabárez que es todo una
insignia del fútbol sudamericano pero
que evidentemente
y a partir de sus declaraciones además
empezará a sufrir un recambio por el
otro lado tenemos a chile que se
sostiene en esta generación dorada en la
que lo llevo la que la llevó a hacer
bicampeona de américa que mantiene ese
nivel competitivo alto y que incluso más
allá de algunas situaciones
extradeportivas que siempre suelen
afectar este equipo se mantiene dando
pelea
que más se puede ver sobre todo teniendo
en cuenta que ayer terminó con algunas
bajas por lesión es un equipo que tiene
jugadores que toman muy buenas
decisiones y creo que eso hace la
diferencia eso marca la diferencia en
cuanto a jerarquía y aprovechar los
momentos del partido en los que hayan
dominado durante todo el encuentro pero
los momentos en los que tienen el
dominio eso lo logran concretar y sacar
resultados muy interesante lo que están
logrando vargas vivir erecto que
pareciera que llevarán mucho tiempo
jugando juntos este gol del equipo
chileno realmente es maravilloso sacan
de zona tanto a godín como a jiménez en
ese primer gol y se hizo ver mal un
equipo que normalmente defiende bien
como es uruguay
la gran aparición es sin duda a bretón
hasta aquí para chile claro que sí
un jugador nacionalizado por pedido
primero de reinaldo rueda y que ahora lo
ha sabido capitalizar muy bien martín
lasarte en su proceso bien ahora pasamos
entonces a la eurocopa que comienza a
definir su mapa de los octavos de final
en el primer turno del lunes en países
bajos en selló su pase con un 3 a 0 ante
macedonia del norte y austria clasificó
como segundo ante ucrania que ahora
espera por otros resultados para ver si
puede clasificar como uno de los mejores
terceros en el grupo b
bélgica venció 2 a 0 a finlandia y cerró
una fase de grupos de eurocopa con
puntaje perfecto por primera vez en su
historia y dinamarca logró la épica con
una goleada 4 a 1 ante rusia para hacer
escolta tenemos ya dos cruces de octavos
de final confirmados italia ante austria
y gales ante dinamarca y hoy se cierra
el grupo d con croacia escocia y
república checa- enfrentando a
inglaterra tras la histórica campaña de
bélgica su entrenador roberto martínez
ya piensa en lo que viene
mates team spin creo que este equipo ha
sido muy consistente en los últimos
cinco años y se trata de tener a cada
individuo en su mejor momento en este
periodo artist periféricos de wii play
en sevilla ahora jugaremos en sevilla
donde hará mucho calor y el campo va a
estar lento necesitamos adaptarnos y que
cada jugador esté preparado para mejorar
el equipo pacha para bélgica y países
bajos cerraron una fase de grupo con
puntaje ideal lo que cualquiera podría
esperar pero da la sensación que todavía
tienen algo más para dar sí yo creo que
en bélgica lo mejor es que logró
recuperar fichas muy importantes como
son bits el eden hazard que puede ser
recambio y por supuesto kevin de bruyne
que llegó después de esa lesión en la
final de la de la champions league y que
ya está plenamente en su mejor nivel
hemos visto esa conexión con lukaku es
un equipo que por momentos por supuesto
ante equipos que se les cierran le ha
costado llegar al área rival o más
meterse y generar daño en el área rival
pero creo que es eso estamos viendo una
evolución positiva sobre todo en una
fase de grupos en la que en la
eliminación directa va a poner más de
presente ese talento colectivo que
seguramente va a alcanzar
martín
equipo de países bajos que llegó con el
cuestionamiento sobre todo sobre la
figura de frank de boer pero que empieza
a mostrar no sólo un rendimiento
colectivo aceptable aunque todavía se le
vienen los desafíos más importantes sino
buenas individualidades como memphis
depay o sorpresas como dan friz en el
lateral derecho sin duda creo que los
cuestionamientos eran más fuertes que el
rendimiento que ha logrado en países
bajos en el torneo es eso vemos un
colectivo que aún le falta sostenerse
más durante varios momentos de los
partidos pero creo que la figura de
memphis depay como ese conductor y sobre
todo ese gestor anímico del equipo ha
sido fundamental el sistema que se le
cuestionaba tanto a frank de boer ha
dado resultado es un equipo que logra
este puntaje perfecto en la primera
ronda y que sin duda
no tiende a ser el gran favorito por el
nivel de juego mostrado pero sin duda
estos equipos en las fases de
eliminación pueden dar sorpresa un
párrafo aparte también me dice lo que
ocurrió con dinamarca que tras el
episodio de eriksen y después de dar la
sensación que merecía algo más si no se
le estaba dando
cumplió con creces con la misión que
tenía ante un público fervoroso en
copenhague estos torneos tienen esto más
allá de lo futbolístico porque también
lino marca lo merecía es un equipo que
siempre fue a buscar los partidos un
equipo que propuso y que tuvo que jugar
este primer encuentro después de la
situación tan fuerte que vivió eriksen
en el campo creo que logró ese premio
ese premio
jugando un muy buen partido ante rusia
que se le vieron muchos defectos en
defensa pero creo que se sonó la épica y
un momento para recordar además jugando
ante sus aficionados creo que esto hizo
ya empieza a marcar una de las postales
de esta eurocopa hasta aquí es todo muy
positivo estamos hablando de aquellos
que les fue bien pero quisiera poner la
lupa también en el rival de dinamarca
ayer rusia que venía de un buen mundial
obviamente empujado por la localía en
2018 y que termina despidiéndose en una
primera fase y dejando muchas dudas de
cara al proceso que viene sobre todo en
la figura de cheste soft claro esos
cuartos de final ilusionaban ilusionaban
con un equipo competitivo realmente ayer
tuvo ese problema no tuvo muchos errores
en zona defensiva y en equipo
dinamarca que insiste e insiste e
insiste creo que es lo hizo ver muy mal
sí creo que este torneo al final empieza
a decantarse también dependiendo de los
grupos y de la competitividad algunos
con menos puntos y menos fútbol van a
lograr clasificarse y bueno lo de rusia
queda allí
y ver también cómo se mantienen esos
procesos y el temas de entrenador o el
tema de esta generación de jugadores que
hace parte de un colectivo que necesita
digamos ese punto diferencial para
lograr superar este tipo de zonas
perfecto ahora seguimos entonces con
otras noticias en diario de copas
repasando otras novedades vinculadas en
este caso a la euro 2020
la federación inglesa confirmó que ben
willie mays on mount estarán ausentes
hasta el 28 de junio inclusive tras
haber estado en contacto con el escocés
bill y gilmore quien dio positivo por
kobe 19 no van a jugar esta tarde ante
república checa y no estarían en los
octavos de final si inglaterra clasifica
como segundo de su grupo
ante la amenaza de perder la final el
gobierno británico habilitó 160 mil
fanáticos para las semifinales y para la
definición de la eurocopa en el estadio
de wembley en londres los asistentes
tendrán que haber recibido las dos dosis
de la vacuna al menos 14 días antes del
partido o mostrar un test de antígenos
negativo
la uefa previó que la allianz arena de
múnich s ilumine con los colores
arcoiris para alemania hungría en apoyo
a los derechos lgtb amenazados en
hungría por una controvertida ley el
alcalde de munich cuestionó la decisión
y prometió poner símbolos lgp en otros
puntos de la ciudad
y esta eurocopa también para cerrar
brevemente nos está entregando este tipo
de cuestiones cuestiones políticas que
se vinculan con el fútbol y que dejan un
poco mal parado a la uefa sí ojalá que
estos temas de diversidad inclusión y
equidad no se queden sólo en las
campañas no en las fotos lindas sino que
en este tipo de situaciones ojalá pueda
ponerse al presente que es un tema de
derechos humanos ojalá la uefa hubiera
actuado diferente perfecto muchísimas
gracias ahora por su compañía y muchas
gracias a ustedes por estar del otro
lado sigan con más en france 24 y
france24 puntocom